hallo leute mit bei sie kamen diese
woche sind wir haben eigentlich die
ganze woche im bett gelegen
deshalb bin ich rausgehen um eine easy
german episode für euch aufzunehmen aber
wir haben uns gedacht wir können euch
auch einfach mal zeigen was hier drin so
passiert deshalb machen wir diese woche
mal eine episode über das kranksein
zeigen uns zeigen euch mal was wir dabei
so machen ja mal verliert ist mir
schlecht
mir geht es schlecht und wie schlecht
könnte das etwas genauer beschreiben von
bratislava
ich bin nicht mehr krank aber ich bin
noch sehr erschöpft ich bin müde und
matt und einfach platt hat dann bist du
noch angst wir zeigen euch jetzt mal was
wir diese woche alles gemacht haben ok
als erster zeigen wir euch einfach mal
unsere wohnung damit ihr seht wie wir so
leben wir wohnen im nordosten von berlin
und haben eine relativ kleine wohnung 54
quadratmetern mit zweitem an dass es das
erste zimmer und in diesem kanal
befindet sich unser bestes um das
schlafzimmer aber gleichzeitig auch
unser wohnzimmer und mein arbeitszimmer
alles in einem
hier wird sich immer und arbeiter guck
mal hier das ist um meinen arbeitsplatz
damit alles gemanagt germans und wir
gehen jetzt mal weiter hier ist der flur
dahinter befindet sich das badezimmer in
dem badezimmer gibt es ja alles was es
so im badezimmer gibt toilette
waschbecken badewannen ja jetzt gehen
wir mal weiter in das herzstück der
wohnung nämlich die kirche die
gleichzeitig janisch zimmer ist und hier
sehen wir auch schon mal sitzen - ich
möchte gerne die zuschauer zeigen wie du
immer vor dem rechner hengst auch gerne
hallo kannst du noch mal zeigen so wie
du so sitzt die am spanischen ziemlich
witzig wenn man krank es andere leute
freuen sich ja dass sie einfach dem bett
liegen und mitmachen
januar muss immer sitzt egal wie
schlecht es hingeht er wird am rechner
und er guckt youtube-videos oder macht
irgendwas er muss immer einfach machen
wolle leute hier zeigen wir euch mal die
verschiedenen phasen bis krank sein
phase eins sich hundeelend spiel
mir geht es schlecht
phase 2 und schüttelfrost ich verbringe
mit bitte noch eine decke bringt mir
noch eine der ersten jahre bring mir
bitte noch eine es noch folgt drei
verwaltungen
[Musik]
probleme machen lassen
phase 4 im bett liegen und fernseh
gucken vater fünf sich selbst
bemitleiden phase sechs freunde anrufen
und wissen mit leiden lachen leben krank
[Musik]
völlig diffus aufs jahr gesehen
bis auf dem weg der besserung befinden
so und jetzt gehen wir euch noch ein
paar tipps was man machen kann wenn man
krank ist nicht gut drauf sein ich bin
selber krank falls ihr das wird nicht
gemerkt hat sich florian eingegipst gibt
natürlich immer so ein paar alte
bewährte hausmittel hin wenn man ja es
ist greift man darauf nicht zurück weil
man macht alles immer wie weit wie
normal weiter und da wundert man sich da
zeit ständig beschnitten hat aber wenn
man kein geld vor allem wenn man etwas
mit dem magen hat sollte man aufpassen
dass man sich sehr einfach ernährt und
bestimmte sachen sollte man vermeiden
zum beispiel ganz süße sachen fettige
sachen was immer sehr gut ist das kein
er bestimmt schnell mal in deutschland
vermarktet das altbewährte zwieback
näher an die verpackung hatte schon
einige davon gegessen januar die
härteste sehr gut gemacht hier halten
privat für den pc darüber hinaus kümmern
natürlich das kann man natürlich sollte
man zum beispiel keinen kaffee trinkt
der ist auch nicht gut für den magen
habt ihr auch schon meine tomaten körper
gemacht die wolltest du auch nicht essen
aber ich habe selber kauft weight
watchers und jetzt wollen wir mal gucken
was sie so fit für und hat tipps für
mich ganz viel trinken tee und wasser
ohne kohlensäure müssten t kampf
aufnehmen dann mit so schönen den
elektrolythaushalt wieder aufbaut
salzige sachen essen aber nicht ganz so
ein bisschen ganz leicht ich glaube ich
etwas gut sein sollte
die ausbildung ist täglich frauen glück
eine nicht geringe abstellen liebe leute
davor unsere entwürfe für heute mit dem
titel kein beiden jahres hat mir
gefallen
sehr gefallen gibt es schon besser nach
den ganzen tollen tipps bewahrt hatten
es geht mir besser wenn ich dran denke
dass hier gleich weg danke ja nicht
meinte die zuschauer oder mich ich bin
ja wir hoffen es hat euch gefallen zu
und leid dass wir heute nicht rausgehen
konnten aber wir hoffen wir haben euch
ein paar mögliche vokabel näher gebracht
falls ihr mal krankheit und darüber auf
deutsch zu sprechen weil wir haben noch
eine kleine ankündigung für euch wir
werden nämlich in der übernächsten woche
also eine woche nachdem dieses video
rauskommt werden wir unsere nächste easy
german tour begeben und die haben wir
noch gar nicht angekündigt und das wir
euch jetzt mitteilen
wir fahren nämlich nach polen nach
tschechien und nach österreich und
bayern all das zusammen mit drei wochen
unterwegs sie haben es in dein
heimatland freust du dich schon die hohe
zahl
ja es ist gar nicht so gut drauf war ja
noch kein geld aber ihr werdet sehen wir
werden uns freunde werden dort einige
schulen besuchen
sie werden dort einige von euch treffen
sie werden auch abends stammtische haben
und zwar im wortsinn katowice und in
krakow und werden dort zuschauer treffen
also euch wenn ihr in polen seit und in
diesen städten wohnt dann guckt
unbedingt auf unsere website easy german
dot org dort werden wir alle termine
aufschreiben und folgt und auch
unbedingt bei facebook facebook.com
fläche the german videos da werdet ihr
alle events und termine finden wir
freuen uns dass ihr heute zu gesehen
habt und wir freuen uns wahnsinnig wenn
wir euch auf tour treffen können in wien
werden wir auch ein stammtisch am und
inside so werden wir unter anderem seien
mit matthias und diese orte auch
vorstellen
und wenn ihr lust habt übungen zu machen
das vokabular von heute das krankheits
vokabular noch mal eingehen das üben
dann können sie auch einen bachelor
werden das geht hier unten und wir
freuen uns auf eure unterstützung danke
schön dass ihr da wart pc's und gute
besserung gerne strecke